bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 21 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nous inviter
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition pascal
thévenot élu député de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines avec 72 25
% des suffrages le candidat les
républicains soutenus par lully et le
modem s'est largement imposé face à
brice ton jacques candidat du parti
socialiste
il est notre invité ce soir réactions et
analyses dans ce journal
aujourd'hui lundi 21 mars est la journée
mondiale de la trisomie 21 une journée
pour sensibiliser le public à cette
maladie
pour nous en parler christian lecoq
président de l'antenne départementale
des yvelines de l'association française
pour la recherche sur la trisomie 21
ouverte à montigny le bretonneux il ya
un an et enfin l'hôpital des nounours a
ouvert ses portes pendant deux jours à
vélizy à versailles sur place dès
nounoursologues ont ausculté plus d'une
centaine de patients en peluche et
accompagnés de leurs propriétaires
destinés aux enfants cette opération
fait découvrir le milieu de la santé de
façon pédagogique et ludique
reportage à suivre et samedi 19 mars la
commémoration de la fin de la guerre
d'algérie s'est tenue dans toute la
france aiguillon pour le maire françois
de ligne et a donné rendez vous devant
le monument le monument pardon aux morts
de la ville le président de
l'association républicaine des anciens
combattants de liancourt et le président
de la fnaca de guyancourt étaient
également présents une minute de silence
a été observée
cette date du 19 mars a été instaurée
sur une proposition du gouvernement de
lionel jospin de 2002 même la boutique
en 2012 elle symbolise le cessez-le-feu
de la guerre au lendemain des accords
d'evian aujourd'hui m
vise la droite estime qu'il s'agit d'un
déni de vérité soulignons le massacre
des artistes survenus après le
cessez-le-feu
pour le maire de billancourt comme pour
les associations le 19 mars reste une
date pleine de sens écouter tous les 19
mars à guyancourt nous avons cette
commémoration
depuis plusieurs décennies et donc sans
aucune polémique artificielle sur la
date puisque ce sont les associations
d'anciens combattants qui trouve
qu'effectivement cette date a du sens
par rapport à l'histoire l'objectif
c'est de commémorer donc le 19 mars à la
mémoire de l'ensemble des victimes je
dis bien de l'ensemble des victimes
civiles et militaires
c'est une date pour nous appelés du
contingent qui représente la fin de la
guerre naf adhérer de tous les risques
qu'on a couru là-bas le cessez-le-feu
ce signifié maintenant on va pouvoir
montrer et ce soir nous recevons en
plateau pascal à thévenot maire de
vélizy villacoublay est élue ce week-end
de la 2e circonscription des yvelines
aux élections législatives partielles
bonsoir à vous dis merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors vous avez
largement remporté dimanche l'élection
législative partielle dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines qui vous
opposait au second tour au candidat
socialiste tristan jacques vous avez
obtenu 72 25 % des suffrages contre 27,7
du 75 % pour votre adversaire vous
attendez assez déçu non je m'attendais à
une issue favorable vu les éléments du
premier tour mais pas autant
des lecteurs qui nous avait fait
confiance on imaginé par dépasser 70%
alors selon vous à cette victoire c'est
dur au monde de popularité des partis
socialistes au gouvernement
oui nul doute que le gouvernement est
sanctionné à travers ça mais c'est aussi
une connaissance de la circonscription
un travail depuis 13 ans de valérie
pécresse qui aussi a marqué les esprits
et là dans cette continuité
bon je pense que la dynamique a été à la
fois sur le bilan de valérie pécresse
sur les engagements que j'ai pris ma
personnalité
et puis une sanction au gouvernement que
l'on peut retrouver dans toutes nos
rencontres avec les citoyens de la
circonscription fait peut-être la
différence est justement dans votre
compagne par rapport à ses portes et nos
valeurs en faites pas avoir peur de
soutenir l'emploi de critiquer le
gouvernement qui est il le fallait de
porter aussi des messages sur
l'innovation avec ma connaissance de
l'entreprise de l'emploi de la formation
et puis simplement d'aller à la
rencontre en fait des habitants de la
circonscription
et puis j'avais aussi c'est un travail
d'équipé puisque tous les maires en fait
me soutenait et m'accompagner en fait
dans cette réflexion et dans cette
rencontre avec les habitants
alors à tristan jacques que votre
adversaire qui était donc candidat pour
le parti socialiste a obtenu 27 75 % des
suffrages on écoute tout de suite sa
réaction
ceci ne s'est plaint c'est bon pour deux
points le premier essai c'est la non
mobilisation de l'électorat puisque
puisqu'uniquement 1 6 % des électeurs se
sont rendus aux urnes
comme je disais déjà la semaine dernière
c'est vraiment l'échec de notre système
pratique qui vont vraiment commencer à
le repenser en profondeur
après c'est un échec pour pour paul ps
pour la candidature malgré le fait que
j'ai pris mes distances notamment sur un
vélo travail les électeurs n'ont pas été
convaincus pour notre jeune plomb je
pouvais apporter leur soutien à tristan
jacta est assez dur et le dresse un
constat assez dur avec le parti
socialiste forcément je pense que vous
êtes d'accord ce que l'on retiendra de
cette élection c'est la victoire des
candidats
public tient même dans les autres
circonscriptions c'est ainsi pour la
droite
oui je pense que c'est un signe pour une
espérance en fait pour 2017
mais je pense que c'est le constat en
fait et est à l'opposé de ce que 10 rue
saint-jacques je pense que si le
gouvernement est sanctionné c'est pas
parce qu'il a porté la loi y compris
c'est simplement parce qu'il n'a pas de
vision et parce que on la vérité
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas ratée de demain
et qui s'il avait su accompagner a
expliqué cette loi qui étaient
améliorées il y aurait selon lui la
population qui aura duré puisque en fait
j'ai jamais eu de réflexion par rapport
à donner de l'emploi en fait aujourd'hui
je pense que parti socialiste se trompe
à vouloir protéger les salariés qui ne
sont pas obligatoirement malmené par
cette loi mais ils oublient tous les
jeunes qui font plutôt à la recherche
d'un emploi cas le sauvegarder et tous
les chômeurs et qui aimerait bien
accéder à l'emploi
alors on reviendra justement sur cette
fois en fin de notre entretien ce que
l'on retiendra également de sélection
c'est le très faible taux de
participation 20 6 12% 73,98 88 %
d'abstention au total et 71e de 70% dans
votre commune quand vous analysez ce
phénomène en fait c'est au départ
surprenant mais quand on analyse les
chiffres de toutes les partiels c'est la
difficulté de mobiliser pour une
partielle puisque c'est pas vraiment
médiatisé et je rencontrais encore entre
les deux tours
délisia qui n'avaient pas percuté sur le
fait qu une élection et qui en écoutant
les résultats me féliciter mais ces
excuses ne pas avoir voté au premier
tour
donc je pense que c'est là toute la
difficulté d'une partielle
sachant qu'après en faisant une bonne
campagne on arrive à mobiliser à vélizy
74% au bout de deux ans de mandat
je pense que ça montre qu'on est sur le
bon chemin et les contrats continuer à
mener nos projets et surtout à apaiser
le climat qui était très tendue
important sur notre territoire
en fait on a beaucoup parlé de valérie
pécresse oui puisqu'en fait depuis
qu'elle est à la présence la région ile
de france tout le monde s'aperçoit que
finalement il ya une région qui existent
puisque l'on parle des projets de
semaine valérie pécresse quasiment tous
les jours dans les médias mais on ne
parle pas obligatoirement de cette
partielle alors justement est ce que
c'est une pression de plus pour vous de
reprendre le siège de valérie pécresse
une pression non mais chalenge une
responsabilité certes puisque elle a
marqué de son passage par rapport à tous
les projets elle avait commencé par le
projet contre les puits de pétrole et
puis elle a permis aussi de développer
toute la circonscription et puis donner
confiance aussi à ses électeurs et de
travailler aussi en équipe avec tous les
maires de la circonscription tous les
conseillers départementaux et je pense
que oui c'est un challenge à lever et la
barre et à ses autres mais avec passion
je pense qu'on peut y arriver il vous
reste un peu de temps moins d'un an à
siéger comment ça va se passer comment
vous envisagez justement c'est arrivé il
reste moins d'un an fin un peu plus d'un
an mais il est clair que là les sujets
le sujet de l'emploi va être aujourd'hui
on n'a pas le temps on n'a pas le droit
d'attendre encore un an avant de se
poser la question de pourquoi la france
est le seul pays pas trouvé de
croissance aujourd'hui
et puis aussi des sujets locaux il ya la
ligne 18 qui va être un sujet l'immédiat
il ya le la banque hre de films
numériques
dans toute la vallée de chevreuse où on
parle souvent de zones blanches mais on
oublie qu'un quelques kilomètres de
paris
finalement on n'est pas mieux loti donc
là il ya aussi de beaux sujets locaux
qui vont être apportées et je pense que
cette année sera mise à profit pour
pouvoir continuer la dynamique cake
actuellement l'intimidation contre x
vous parlez de la loi de travail
il ya quelques instants vous entrerez
dès demain dans les mystiques vous allez
poser votre première question
d'actualité justement au gouvernement
concernant cette loi elle conneries
quelle position allez vous adopter
justement si vous allez non alors
aujourd'hui la première question oui bon
je vais y travailler en quittant le
plateau reste à définir par contre c'est
clair que la belle connerie restera un
sujet mais totalement vidée de son sens
et que finalement on a peut-être pu en
entendre parler que ça sera ça devait
être une loi qui devait redonner
confiance aux chefs d'entreprise pour
embaucher et là en fait c'est une loi
qui se transforme de nouvelles
contraintes pour les pme je pense pas
qu'il ya une mobilisation dans la rue je
pense que c'est plutôt on s'aperçoit une
déconnexion totale entre les élus du
parti socialiste qui siègent à
l'assemblée nationale et les citoyens
qui sont prêts à avoir évolué les choses
à voir de grandes réformes pour
améliorer l'emploi dans notre pays
vous êtes donc maire de vélizy
villacoublay je le rappelle
vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
président la société d'économie mixte de
vélizy donc c'est mieux maintenant
député de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines
que répondez vous à ceux qui vous
accusent de cumuler les mandats
notamment je pense aux groupes
d'opposition de droite rance on peut
pour vélizy qui s'interroge sur le site
le temps que vous allez consacré à
chacune de vos fonctions en fait c'est
la seule critique ils ont trouvé donc en
vigueur
s'il n'y a pas grand chose a porté sur
la politique menée sur vélizy mais
aujourd'hui mais encore hier pendant ma
tournée des bureaux de vote
télévision quand il me posait une
question c'était surtout très fier que
je sois députés mais que je reste au
maire puisque c'est un monde à qui se
complètent et quand j'ai toujours mené
avec passion mais mandat et je
continuerai
mené avec passion et détermination et je
pense que c'est plutôt une chance pour
lui et c'est comme ça que le voient tous
les visions l'année prochaine vous allez
retravaillé pour la reprendre votre
siège finalement on pourra peut-être pas
cumuler ces bombes à la comment ça va se
dérouler pour car non je suis assez
optimiste en fait parce que quand on
discute avec tous les élus hélas et
trans partisan je pense que il y un
dogme mais ce n'est pas la seule voie
qui fera changer mais je pense que le
vrai
la vraie réforme en limite de cumul de
mandat c'est de limiter à un mandat
national un mandat local
je pense que c'est ce qui sera proposé
l'année prochaine donc cesser
complètement compatible très bien merci
beaucoup au bascala thévenot d'être venu
dans son a3 tôt et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
merci tout autre sujet à présent si une
opération qui est en place depuis
maintenant dix ans elle est mise en
place par la nef est coordonnée par
l'association poèmes des étudiants en
médecine de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'hôpital des
nounours oh vers ses portes pendant deux
jours le 15 et le 18 mars à vélizy et à
versailles destinée aux enfants de
grande section de maternelle a pour
objectif de faire découvrir le milieu de
la santé de façon pédagogique et ludique
grâce aux étudiants en médecine un
reportage signé william l c'est un
hôpital un peu spécial un hôpital qui
ouvre une fois par an où les patients
sont des peluches sabrina accompagne son
nounours petit ours brun qui a la grippe
première étape consultation avec un
docteur pour le diagnostic chez dans la
salle des consultations et donc on
s'occupe d'accueillir les enfants avec
leurs nounours et de leur demander
le problème qu'ils ont
le prénom de leur noce leur prénom à eux
aussi et on met un peu en marche le
début des soins prise de température
prescription de médicaments petit ours
brun aura même droit à un carnet de
santé une carte vitale avant de passer
en salle de soins
maintenant le ciel dr qu'est ce qu'on va
faire alors vu qu'il a lagrive qui ont
néanmoins fièvre il a un peu chose rare
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va le mettre
une compresse fois sabrina pourra même
participer aux soins de sunu l'ours
comme un premier contact avec le monde
des blouses blanches aujourd'hui ce qui
est hélas la grille parce qu'elle avait
un petit peu les craintes qu'elle est
wallon ont péri ici tout est prévu bloc
opératoire dentiste ou radiographie
aujourd'hui ce sont 110 enfants de
grande section de maternelle qui auront
amené leur nounours pour une première
sensibilisation qui profite à tout le
monde c'est surtout un peu une première
sensibilisation parce qu'en 4ème année
on a un stage obligatoire de pédiatrie
donc on se retrouve confronté aux
enfants auxquels on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de se comporter avec eux et
du coup le pic est lé nounours c'est un
peu une première approche pour nous pour
s'habituer on leur rappelle des la
consultation les présents que ça se
soigne très bien et à la fin du parcours
on leur rappelle que le nom s'est soigné
dans la salle d'attenté on revient les
voir pour vérifier que le nounours
faisant soigner leur rappeler et on
retourne même dans les classes deux
semaines plus tard pour leur rappeler
leurs noms se soigner aujourd'hui c'est
une trentaine d'étudiants en médecine de
seconde année qui ont opéré toute la
journée dans un hôpital où chaque
patient au sort guéri aujourd'hui lundi
à 21 mars est la journée mondiale de la
trisomie 21 pour nous en parler ce soir
en plateau avec nous christian lecoq
bonsoir vous êtes président de l'antenne
départementale des yvelines de
l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21 qui est à
montigny le bretonneux
cette journée vise donc à sensibiliser
le grand public car c'est encore une
maladie méconnue
oui tout à fait oui alors une maladie
méconnue mais quand même je vais vous
donner quelques chiffres
cinq cent mille personnes en france
cinq cent cinquante mille excuses à
50000 personnes en france 500 mises en
europe et 5 millions dans le monde
vous avez ouvert l'antenne il ya un an
ou alors ça s'est passé depuis
alors en 2014 on a ouvert une antenne 2
puis bon on a donc sollicité les toutes
les communes du 78 on va solliciter
aussi les les entreprises pour récupérer
des subventions donc on a déjà récupéré
des subventions en 2015 et donc on
continue sur 2016 et des années qui
suivent si vous avez du mal à mobiliser
les communes ou les entreprises
justement pour trouver des bons pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21
oui on a beaucoup de mal alors que je
suis encore re donner des chiffres sur
le 78 on a envoyé 2 562 courrier pour
toutes les communes du 78 et sur les 262
il y en a que 50 qui ont répondu donc
2016 va être une relance sur les
communes qui n'ont pas répondu et sur
les 50 on a eu que trois communes qui
nous ont donné une subvention
comment vous expliquez afin justement
c'est soit si difficile de mobiliser les
gens sur cette maladie a aujourd'hui
c'était surtout les les personnes
concernées qui est donné des dons ou des
subventions et on s'aperçoit que au
niveau des communes ils ont beaucoup de
mal à participer
à donner à cette pathologie alors vous
proposez voilà des accueils justement
les premiers marque premier mercredi du
mois
c'est ça les deuxièmes derrière les yeux
moi voilà du moins donc à montigny c'est
l'accompagnement aux familles c'est de
l'information qu'est ce que vous
proposez
alors cessez de l'aide et de
l'accompagnement aux familles concernées
et ont donc c'est le 2e mercredi du
moura 15 allée des épines à montigny le
bretonneux donc toutes les personnes qui
veulent venir s'informer ou avoir des
enseignements surtout n'hésitez pas à
venir
alors vous rencontrer à peut-être des
familles qui sont en détresse qui ne
savent pas trop vers quelle institution
se tourner voilà et puis bon visons
souvent donc un enfant handicapé et donc
ils savent pas pour le sommeil issa
froid pour certaines choses et donc on
n'arrive pas à leur donner de
renseignements est-ce qu'il ya
suffisamment voilà d'institutions ou
peut-être de choses allaient se tourner
et qu'on a un enfant handicapé utile de
la trisomie atteint de la trisomie 21
pour aider pour voilà à faire les
démarches à aujourd'hui c'est surtout au
niveau de l'association au niveau
national que qui s'est implantée à paris
diderot
c'est là où on peut avoir beaucoup plus
de renseignements
concernant cette pathologie depuis donc
que vous avez le nantais n'a été créé en
l'ouverture l'année dernière donc en
2015 vous avez des actions prévues
qu'est-ce que vous avez mis en place
voilà pour ce faire parler de vous aussi
sensibiliser les gens à cette maladie
alors la sensibilisation on l'a fait
via le forum des associations à
montigny-le-bretonneux
on participe aussi à la semaine du
handicap
la dernière le dernier jour pour donner
des renseignements ont fait monter un
stand au mois de juin
on participait aussi à la semaine du
handicap dans la ville des bureaux qui
nous ont contactés donc on va s'y
déplacer pour vous avez réalisé
également en octobre une soirée avec
france alzheimer yvelines pour voilà
vous m'utiliser utiliser les moyens peut
être faire plus pareil vous pourquoi
justement avoir choisi cette association
on a choisi de l'association française
des moeurs
yvelines parce que entre cette maladie
là et donc la trisomie 21
il ya quelques gènes qui sont
correspondants et donc ils ont bien
voulu accepter et donc on organise une
soirée festive et on a un buffet qui est
proposé par le restaurant la fontaine
qui est située à montigny-le-bretonneux
alors il ya donc pour la journée
mondiale vous avez organisé voilà à
montigny un événement afin de récolter
des dons pour justement la recherche ce
soir vous avez également une autre un
autre événement qui est prévu vous m'en
dire un petit peu plus voilà donc ce
soir il ya une conférence qui ce qui se
situe à la salle jacques brel à
montigny-le-bretonneux à 20h30
et donc c'est sur l'énergie sur
l'énergie et alors pourquoi 7,7 qu'on
participe à cette conférence c'est que
le une partie de la somme récoltée sera
reversée à l'association
donc il ya voilà un tissu associatif je
t'aime très vivant et qui vous aident
quand même sur saint quentin en yvelines
merci beaucoup christian legault qui
vous voulez plus d'information ou voilà
sur la recherche consacrés à la trisomie
regardez sur statham est à frt 78 point
fr vous y retrouverez toutes les
informations
merci beaucoup à vous et merci d'être
venus en plateau pour répondre à nos
questions et on parle à présent de sport
aujourd'hui les questions du handball
féminin l'équipe de france des moins de
20 ans remporté son ticket pour les
championnats du monde de la catégorie
les bleuettes ont réalisé un sans faute
dans le tournoi de qualification de
plaisir en s'imposant contre la slovénie
israël et la macédoine un reportage
signé michael et demi d'euros et camille
lambert libido vibrer au rythme du rugby
ce week-end
de france des moins de 20 ans était un
plaisir pour participer au tournoi
international juniors une compétition
qualificative pour les championnats du
monde 2016 qui relie c'est la slovénie
la macédoine et israël après deux
victoires contre les slovènes 30 à 29 et
contre les israëliens 44 à 16 la france
se jouer sa qualification contre la
macédoine ce dimanche un match qu'elles
ont dominée de bout en bout score final
33 à 21 h et on est content après je
sais que mon dieu ils ont su répondre au
défi
grâce à toute la préparation et à leur
côté professionnel est anticipée dans la
réussite
dominés les macédoniennes donc voila
c'était la dernière étape on savait que
le plus dur s'arrête ce serait les
slovènes
aux quatre défaites on aurait été privé
du mondial donc on est on
on est vraiment très heureux avec cette
première place du tournoi les bleus
s'envoleront pour la russie en juillet
prochain pour tenter de remporter la
couronne mondiale de la catégorie face
aux meilleures nations internationale
il ya des écuries beaucoup plus forte
que nous mais faut croire en ce qu'on
proposait il faut faut rester à
travailler et dans la discipline s'est
rattrapé les meilleurs parce que voilà
les a disposées dans ton n'a pas fait
des supers résultats pendant les
championnats d'europe 2015 les bleuettes
avec un mail que glorieuse 19e place en
espagne
et vous avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler d'elle où vous êtes vous l'avez
vu sur internet samedi et mac et cup une
youtube eux étaient présents pour
rencontrer ses fans dans le centre
commercial de vélizy 2 mais l'événement
ne s'est pas déroulé comme prévu elle
explique dans cette vidéo que vous voyez
à l'écran
cette jeune il viennoise qui totalisent
plus de 700 mille abonnés été obligé
d'écourter sa séance de dédicaces et de
photos car les fans étaient trop
nombreux la sécurité n'était pas en
mesure d'assurer le bon déroulement de
l'événement quelques centaines de
personnes était attendue alors que ce
sont plus de 2000 fans qui sont venus
rencontrer la lutte du buzz elle s'est
excusé pour l'incident provoqué et nous
accueillons comme chaque lundi sephora
namani pour la chronique culturelle
bonsoir sephora ou saint flour sephora
qui va nous parler du dernier spectacle
dont j'ai l'impresion cage retour à
bérat tam
oui tout à fait alors deux
représentations vendredi et samedi soir
avait lieu au théâtre de saint quentin
en yvelines de retour à bérat tam
spectacle créé en 2015 pour les 30 ans
de la compagnie d'angelin preljocaj or
angelin prejlocaj pour ceux qui ne le
connaîtraient pas très bien c'est tout
simplement le chorégraphe français le
plus joué dans le monde il chorégraphie
notamment pour l'opéra national de paris
et compte plus de cinquante créations
aussi bien classiques que conceptuel
alors j'ai une pré local présentait les
quatre saisons en 2006 blanche neige en
2009 des ballets classiques et puis ce
que j'appelle oublier en 2012 et
l'ennemi en 2013 qui sont des pièces
plus contemporaines
oui tout à fait et puis donc avec sa
création ce que j'appelle l'oubli de
il avait déjà souhaité marié le texte et
la danse il renouvelle l'expérience avec
retour à bérat tam spectacle pour lequel
il a commandé un texte à l'écrivain
laurent mauvignier et sur scène
s'harmonisent onze danseurs et trois
comédiens un beau challenge en fait qu
essayer de d'arriver à marier de manière
extrêmement égale le texte et la danse
en fait
edouard comment aussi un chorégraphe son
parent d'un texte aujourd'hui comment un
auteur accepte qu'un chorégraphe
s'empare de son texte etc etc
et puis c'est aussi une nouvelle manière
de travailler c'est pas du tout la même
manière travail et de travailler avec un
metteur en scène avec un chorégraphe
le rapport est totalement différent
alors pouvez vous nous en dire
plus sephora sur l'histoire de cette
pièce qui balaie le texte de mauvignier
évoque le retour d'un gène exilé dans sa
ville d'origine berra tam la ville a été
dévastée par la guerre civile et le
recherchent un temps perdu et une femme
son ancien amour katia on est vraiment
confrontés aux ravages de la guerre
civile et à une population meurtrie
c'est une tragédie épique
on retrouve vraiment la signature d'un
j'ai l'impresion cage avec toujours
cette volonté d'amener la violence sur
scène et de provoquer alors ici une
réflexion autour des endroits ravagés
par le chaos dans l'histoire des vins et
21e siècles et de façon plus générale
autour de sujets sensibles
alors faut disait que cette création un
côtoient donc là le texte côtoie la
danse commence ce mail ce travail
artistique
alors c'est vraiment un travail de
complémentarité le texte ne doit pas
prendre le pas sur la danse mais au
contraire le porter il lui prêter ses
intentions ça va être la musicalité du
spectacle qui comme le disait très bien
d'ailleurs laurent cazanave n'est ni une
comédie musicale ni un simple balle est
donc le texte vient rythmer donner vie
et prêter ses intentions danseurs c'est
un travail d'écouté entre les comédiens
et les danseurs c'est un peu notre
musique parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
de ma vie qui a plus une trame médical
antérieur
mais finalement c'est un nous donne un
rythme et tout de suite ça nous plonge
dans l'histoire très facilement et il
faut être à l'écouté beaucoup des
comédiens peut être conscient justement
de leur musicalité vocale et de pouvoir
appréhender justement ça se dire ah ils
sont un peu plus rapides donc il faut
qu'on va anticiper en six ans avec plus
rapide ou plus lent donc on va essayer
de poser un peu plus les choses donc oui
c'est vraiment quelqu'un et que la
musique c'est
c'est un tel procès un rythme quand j'ai
enfin chaque soir ça sera pareil un sac
le travail à l'air singulier en tout cas
ça donne envie de regarder vous avez
bien m'extrader préfet ni bien sûr alors
un extrait de la présentation de cette
création lors de sa présentation au
festival d'avignon dans la cour
d'honneur du palais des papes en juillet
dernier on regarde des femmes sont
arrivés elle maquille le visage de
catllar des hommes jouent de la musique
et danse autour d'elle
deux autres femmes dessinent des
arabesques sénat
la guerre en libye oui on entend
effectivement ça donne envie merci
beaucoup à sephora et on retrouve ce
spectacle le 11 et le 12 avril dans les
yvelines à rueil malmaison tout de suite
vous avez rendez vous avec michael et
demi d'euros pour l'actualité sportive
avec le 7-8 sport c'est la fin de cette
édition je vous retrouve demain et vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée